i just want to feel this first
i just want to hold on to this a little
longer after a three-month hiatus
grey's anatomy returned with an epic
station 19 crossover
that took a devastating turn what
happened
the episode followed dr andrew deluca
trying to trail and
capture a sex trafficker which led him
to getting stabbed
in the chest i think he stabbed me
[Music]
at first the injury seemed to be a brush
with death as deluca seemed to be saved
in surgery
but that all changed once complications
came after the procedure
leading him back to the operation room
where he ended up bleeding out
is somebody going to call it
time of death 2250
fans everywhere were shocked by the
ending but giacomo johnny ot who plays
dr deluca
revealed he's keeping a little hope
alive telling gma what may be next for
his character
if you're a true grey's anatomy fan you
know that characters never die they
always live within the hospitals of
grace alone
and then we have moments like the beach
we have dreams flashbacks so
there's so many different ways for us to
see our characters of the past giacomo
also
opened up to e.t sharing how he felt
about saying goodbye to dr deluca
after seven seasons saying quote i think
this is a good time to exit and have a
fresh start
i was very in love with the story and
the time it took to tell it properly
it's been a really really amazing and
satisfying experience for the past month
and a half shooting this episode
and going through the process of making
it if it were up to you though would you
would you play dulutha for as long as
they wanted you to
uh i love playing de luca but i also
love doing a lot of other things i
started in the theater so
i mean you know as long as i was open to
doing other projects as well then then
yes definitely i am very
very proud of my duluth character he
also adds that when it comes to his
character's ending
he's more than satisfied telling us he
doesn't regret trying to stop that woman
he's always been plagued if you will
about doing the right thing at all costs
unfortunately it cost him his life but
looking back he doesn't regret it
i don't know what happens from here
meredith
neither another person who's seemingly
as devastated as the fans is alan pompeo
who posted this tick tock in response to
last night's episode
and although it may be a while until we
see dr deluca back in the grades
universe
we can always reminisce on moments like
this
i'll miss you
if i go back and you don't i'll miss you
you'll be okay i will be okay